bon alors on peut se demander quel sujet
nous devions traiter en votre honneur or
on a pris ce qu'on appelle vous savez
aujourd'hui un peu facilement des sujets
de société par exemple
bon le désespoir que la morosité c'était
très répandue aujourd'hui et on s'est
avisé que quand tout va mal et que quand
on a envie d'en finir avec l'existence
rien ne vaut un bon copain regarde
et viennet
j'avais compris je suis j'ai compris et
je perds sont ici de creysse
attention
ça va pas la tête
je ne veux plus vivre tu cuisines non on
n'a pas le droit de dire ça mais la vue
c'est beau la vie c'est magique la vie
c'est merveilleux la vie tu te rends
compte que ce que notre existence sans
l'avis un titre en
vue était dans le vent de tam et ses
neuf banques et dans le vent de ta mère
qu'on peu d'avenir il fait tout noir
c'est le néant mouvement contre la vie
c'est un titre
[Rires]
c'est parti c'est le soleil et les
plages at all in pas des soutiens à
trolls de la toile fine du bon choix
c'est ça ou
alors c'est le mental est un petit peu
de plomb dans la cervelle tu réfléchiras
pour que tu veux de supprimer à ckoi
ouais je suis amoureux d'amoureux oui tu
es amoureux et arrêtent tous à cause
d'une gonzesse mais c'est normal d'avoir
du mal avec les gonzesses surtout début
mon père bien commencé à draguer ma mère
pendant l'occupation je suis né au 63 tu
vois
[Musique]
je ne suis pas amoureux d'une femme de
robert je suis amoureux
l'homme était enfin je veux dire t'es
[ __ ] quoi
on va c'est pas dramatique des deux pays
a beau mais c'est bon d'être pdc pourra
naître pour n'avoir alors puis tout le
monde devient peut dès maintenant même
les fans
cocteau disait l'homosexualité c'est
comme la planche à voile il suffit de
s'y mettre il a dit nous souhaitons pas
imputer
d'imaginer un peu si tous les péchés de
la terre se foutent de merrien congrès
que tu vises un peu l'holocauste
c'est comme pour les gros test va le
trouver tu dis que tu le laisses au hiv
1 je lui dis que j'aimerais voir eux
robert je t'aime
écoute robert rejeter
cette idée que c'était arrivé cet été
enfin tu te souviens quand on n'est plus
notre majorité mais leur histoire on
était sous la douche la touriste de
l'actos cornes bizet
m'a fait un petit massage assis le dos
il va venir ça va tout retour dit oui
oui jma est toute ma vie a changé
ta vie ta vie n'y a pas que la vie dans
l'existence
la vie c'est pas très beau la vie des
fois la vie c'est moche la vie la vie
c'est les enfants confiance c'est we are
the world are the children ce cd russe
qui vont nous [ __ ] sur la gueule c'est
de l'auto qu'on peut jamais gagner ans
d'ailleurs ceux qui parlent le mieux de
la vie c'est les morts
étaient en huit ans il y moment
en famille
moi si tu vends une bonne expérience de
la vie il faut mourir
[Musique]
st thomas do bon oui franc tiré dans le
dos ah non
[Musique]